[Musique]
ce sera peut-être l'événement culturel
de 2024 l'an prochain le musée d'orsé à
Paris organisera une grande exposition
sur l'impressionnisme à l'occasion des
150 ans du mouvement pictural en 1874 se
tenait la première exposition
impressionniste l'événement à l'époque a
fait scandale alors de manière
exceptionnelle le musée d'orset va
apprêter plusieurs de ces toiles à des
lieux culturels en région en centrreev
de Loire le musée des BeauxArts de
chartre exposera le bassin au Ninfa
harmonie verte peint en 1899 par Claude
Mony la peinture restera en heure et
Loir du 16 mars au 16 juin 2024 Orléan
accueillera deux tableaux du 5 au 16
mars celui de toulos l'Autrec Louis
bougl et celui d'Auguste Renoir Julie
Manet au total une trentaine de musées
de l'hexagone et de la Réunion recevront
178 chef-dœuvrees
impressionnistes